llegó el momento de repasar la prensa
internacional con rosa pérez de rosa
bienvenida gracias por estar aquí y
nuevamente con nosotros entrevista de
prensa feliz día para ti feliz jueves
vamos a empezar con el tiempo álvaro
uribe que sigue en su caso tras perder
la tutela en la corte y pongamos un poco
en contexto entonces con lo que ocurre
con el expresidente colombiano rosa
buenos días raúl feliz jueves para ti
también volvemos a empezar con un tema
de aquí de colombia y es con el tema con
el que abre este medio colombiano 'el
tiempo' y es un nuevo giro en este caso
que ya lleva años y que se acabó pues
valga la redundancia girando contra el
ex presidente álvaro uribe por su
supuesta implicación en la manipulación
de testigos en un caso más amplio que es
son las denuncias por su supuesta
vinculación también con el
paramilitarismo aquí en colombia bien
esta investigación la llevaba a cabo la
corte suprema porque es el organismo al
que le corresponde investigar y procesar
a las personas aforadas como los
senadores que
el caso del expresidente
sin embargo cuando dejó el senado álvaro
uribe pretendía que este caso quedara
fuera de las competencias de la corte
suprema y que la fiscalía se encargará
de ello si es que se encargaba pero en
todo caso pretendía que todas las
investigaciones las indagaciones que ya
había realizado la corte suprema-
quedaran anuladas bien ahora este esta
cuestión esta disputa sobre quien debe
juzgar que ha caído en manos de la corte
constitucional que tal y como señala el
tiempo ha fallado por cinco votos cinco
votos en contra y cinco votos a favor
perdón y cuatro en contra consideró que
las pruebas y actuaciones de la corte
suprema en el caso de los falsos
testigos conservan validez incluso
después de la renuncia del expresidente
al senado de la república así que vamos
a ver cómo continúa todas estas
investigaciones lo que es seguro es que
aquí lo vamos a hablar así es rosa no
tengan duda de eso pero vamos a hablar
ahora de otro tema que está en
actualidad internacional la tensión en
la frontera entre belarús y la unión
europea específicamente por pueblo con
el monstruo time polonia observa un
incremento de personas migrantes en la
frontera y acusó a belarús de terrorismo
estado rosa exacto como comentabas hemos
centrado mucho la atención en esta
frontera concretamente en esta zona de
esta frontera exterior de la unión
europea que delimita polonia y
básicamente lo que está sucediendo es
que tanto las autoridades polonesas como
la comisión europea como el consejo
europeo están acusando a belarús de
utilizar la migración como una arma
desestabilizadora para la unión europea
a lo que belarús a lukashenko de hecho
responde apoyado por moscú en esta
visión que la unión europea
no está cumpliendo los propios tratados
que ella misma ha firmado y que deber y
con los que debería garantizar la
posibilidad de estas personas de
solicitar asilo y protección
internacional en territorio europeo
además también a putin acusa a la unión
europea de no asumir una vez más las
consecuencias de su política exterior
porque recordemos
por parte de las personas que se
encuentran bloqueadas en esta frontera
provienen de oriente medio y otros
países de otros países de asia y de
áfrica un tema que vamos a seguir
analizando con nuestro segundo invitado
del día en nuestro programa directo
américa vamos ahora con el acuerdo en
glasgow entre china y eeuu primero vamos
a ver el lado estadounidense new york
times dice china y eeuu se unen para
buscar el corte de emisiones del
artículo the black hammer y lisa afirman
exacto hemos querido ver un poco no los
dos puntos de vista de este acuerdo
porque hemos escogido medios que son
bastante afines a sus actuales gobiernos
y empezamos así te parece por el 'new
york times' que dice las dos mayores con
potencias contaminantes sea del planeta
y llegan a un acuerdo pero poco concreto
y señalan que si bien china y eeuu son
rivales y aumentan las tensiones no
entre estos dos polos mundiales en temas
como los derechos humanos o el comercio
pues que han hablado como aliados en la
lucha para mantener el calentamiento
global
es más o menos seguros veremos lo que
acaba sucediendo raúl pero por otro lado
el 'global times' no es tan digamos
escéptico en libertad digamos que se
reserva un poco las dudas sobre
finalmente la eficacia de este acuerdo y
lo que el 'global times' se quiere
significar es que si bien
estos dos países como comentábamos no
ahora delimitan un poco lo que es el
nuevo orden mundial se necesitan y toda
la humanidad los necesita al frente del
liderazgo contra en la cal contra el
cambio climático así ese rosa y bueno
terminamos con imágenes del volcán
cumbre vieja de radiotelevisióncanaria
como también ya estamos dando
seguimiento en nuestra sección de
revista de prensa exacto porque ya van
más de 50 días desde que empezó esta
erupción y tal y como señalan los medios
españoles y los regionales
particularmente como
radiotelevisióncanaria los científicos
no llegan a determinar cuándo es que va
a parar no esta erupción volcánica que
ya ha afectado pues a muchas personas de
la isla de la palma hemos seleccionado
unas imágenes de
esta mañana en europa y también de la
noche de ayer pero les recordamos que en
radio televisión canaria tienen un canal
de youtube donde pueden seguir en
directo y en el segundo segundo mejor
dicho eso es pues cualquier novedad si
la de traeremos a que evidentemente 100%
rosa gracias por toda la información
entonces de los titulares de la prensa
del día de hoy nos vemos mañana viernes
con más revista de prensa en directo
américa vamos a pasar ahora con nuestro
primer invitado el día
[Música]